hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
h1z1 has finally made it over to be a
spa and it's a pretty bloody good game
to play it's a battle royale title just
like you'd expect 100 people fall from
the skies and attempt to be the last
survivor in an ever-shrinking safe zone
the problem is it can be a little
difficult to learn the game's basics at
first so here's a super quick beginner's
guide for anyone who's just picking up
the game I'll also show you how to get
the free PS plus content for hate onesie
1 at the end of the video
anyway this intro is taking far too long
let's do this
without a doubt the first thing you
should know is about bullet drop in h1z1
the bullets are projectiles just like in
real life
this means the bullets must travel from
your gun all the way to the target
I realize that seems ridiculously simple
but on other games like fortnight they
instead use hit scanning to determine
bullet hits on most weapons it's a
little more complex than that but in
fortnight the exact second your gun
shoots it's already reached the target
it's instantaneous in h1z1 regardless of
the weapon you'll need to compensate for
the bullet to reach the target and
bullet drop too so you'll need to aim
slightly in front of a moving target and
depending on distance slightly above
them too
let's talk about your inventory and the
damage system in h1z1 in the early part
of the game scavenging is imperative and
there's a handful of items to look out
for let's ignore guns for now on your
travels you'll find helmets boots body
armor and backpacks although they all
offer aesthetic changes all have
specific purposes helmets give extra
protection to your cranium so if you
don't want to be killed in a single
headshot grab a helmet
similarly with body armor these will
protect your torso boots on the other
hand offers zero protection they instead
will give you a boost to your general
maneuverability and running speed and
surprisingly boots are quite important
when looting quickly or moving from
cover to cover the backpacks offer
additional weapon slots and extra
pockets to carry more loot you'll start
with two weapon slots the backpack you
pick up adds one more and the military
backpack adds one more giving you four
weapon slots in total what are we
talking about inventory
keep in mind that tapping l1 switches to
the next weapon in your arsenal but for
specific selections hold l1 and use the
right thumbstick to handpick your chosen
weapon of death one more thing before we
move on grenades and other chucker balls
are kept separate from your weapon wheel
and can be cycled through using right on
the d-pad
so you've tooled up you've got a weapon
and you're ready to fight the next thing
to understand are those hit markers
which flash white yellow or red if you
see white pop up when you're shooting
this indicates you're hitting a vehicle
yellow displays armor being hit and red
the color of blood indicating you're
hitting a fleshie bit of the enemy there
is another one - green which displays
team damage because there's always one
bellend who team kills like this little
bit a side note here when shot
h1z1 has a bleeding effect shown by this
icon in the bottom corner if left
unchecked you will eventually bleed to
death in the current build of the game a
bandage or a first-aid kit will stop the
bleeding let's talk about the importance
of vehicles without a ride you'll most
likely never reach the final circle the
map is really that vast consider a
vehicle part of your loadout take it
everywhere with you and only discarded
when you find a better option
you'll notice that 99% of cars are gray
and burned-out and alas
these are undriveable but there are ATVs
trucks four-by-fours and police cars
scattered around the world they can also
spawn in and out randomly each vehicle
has pros and cons when compared to
others the ATV leaves you completely
exposed and susceptible to fall damage
but it's found everywhere in the game
it's great for going off-road and it's
pretty bloody fast only outpaced by the
police car the 4x4
aka the Jeep on the other hand has great
handling and can offer Road well and
offers great cover during fights like I
said his pros and cons all around but
for what it's worth the police car would
be my best option oh and keep in mind
the condition of the vehicle and how
much fuel is in the tank is displayed on
the screen so keep an eye out each
vehicle is equipped with turbo so hold
l1 for an injection of Nos
on the negative side this will deplete
your fuel resources a little quicker
right let's look at the main reason
you'll need a vehicle in h1z1 the end
game becomes Carmageddon 10 plus people
alive and driving around in a
destruction derby depending on your
location a vehicle is imperative as it's
your only source of protection and cover
you'll quickly notice h1z1 is a cover
shooter and those stood in the open
become cannon fodder almost immediately
so grab a cap ball by far a truck for
the final circle believe me you will
need it well until the devs release an
EMP grenade to stop the final circle
Carmageddon let's go back to the start
of the game if you've played fortnight
you've been spoiled by the parachuting
system in that game here in h1z1 the
game begins in a similar fashion with
100 competitors parachuting onto the map
sadly we don't have the same amount of
control here but there is a little room
to maneuver holding the down direction
on the right stick will decrease your
altitude immensely the thumbsticks can
then be used to make small adjustments
to generally move you around but forward
and backwards aren't really an option
here instead side to side strafing
method is the most advantageous going
left-right left-right will help descend
slightly quicker to the strafing method
can also be used to get further
distances than you'd expect finally
without a doubt always jump into the
combat zone when first starting each of
your gaming sessions this will warm up
your reactions and reactivate the muscle
memory you have stored away so when you
finally jump into a real game you are
ready 100% not only that the combat zone
is the perfect area to try out each of
the weapons and get a feel for any
changes the developers add at later days
oh we're almost there now come on before
I go let's make sure a few things I've
neglected to say are in place loot has
rarity attached using a color coding
system green purple and finally yellow
or gold if you prefer at a single glance
you'll know the level of quality when
looting corpses crates or supply drops
all those supply drops in early game
will bear green loot before offering
purple mid game and lastly gold in the
final stages of the game the only thing
to do now is claim our PS + goodies if
you're a subscriber to PS +
jump on the star and depending when you
do this it should be found straight
underneath the h1z1 game if it's not use
the search function to find the game and
just below where all the purchase
options are scroll all the way to the
right and lo and behold here's your free
PS plus h1z1 offerings keep in mind
you'll need to restart your game to
receive them and just in case you want
to see them here's what you get right
I'm going back into h1z1 now to try and
progress past my beginner status or a
quick note if you're a h1z1 master or if
you're just a beginner like me please
consider joining our discard I'm
planning to add a h1z1 chat and I'd love
to fill it with great people like you
I'll link the PSG Discogs below I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade thank you for
sticking around till the end I do
appreciate it
I'll see you next time I won't fight
over here fight over here let's get
involved I wonder if I can hit him with
the vehicle without being actually
inside it ok I like this I like this I'm
on board let's do this age ones do you
want